if if I can't tell which are my memories
and which are your memories it's really
hard for us to keep uh to keep distinct
identities so what are the implications
of your work for the concept of identity
yeah yeah no you You' put your finger
exactly on it so so so two two years ago
I I wrote this paper called on the
boundary of the self and it's exactly
this idea it's the way to to uh to
Define what is a self at different
scales and uh how does the boundary the
size of that self change okay over time
and that's exactly the kind of thing
that that you're talking about it's
having having communication channels
that partially wipe the metadata on
information so that I no longer know
whether it came from you or or whether
it came from me if you enjoyed that clip
then the full podcast is out right now
you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcast as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and AI